in demon souls most of the unique
equipment that you do get is from
completing npc
quest lines and if they're wearing or
wielding it
chances are you can get it from them so
use the timestamps to skip to the
characters that you're interested in
and make sure to read the description
also to learn about character tendency
and world tendency since this is a
complicated but
really important mechanic in demon souls
and
a lot of these quest lines rely upon it
one of the most important npcs in the
game
is blacksmith ed located at the bottom
of the rotating platforms at the very
beginning of the stonefang tunnels
to get these platforms moving simply
progress through the first level in a
linear fashion
until you get to this laneway with lava
lizards in a room to your right
proceed straight along this laneway
break through all the rubble
and turn the lever on the cliff face
below is blacksmith ed
who doesn't have a quest line per se but
he can take
boss souls and turn them into unique
boss weapons once you give him a red hot
demon soul
which you get from the flame lurker
later on in this world once you have it
don't consume it give it to ed instead
and come back whenever you get a new
boss soul
to see what you can craft for example
phalanx's lead soul can be combined with
a plus seven
short spear to create the scraping spear
or if you've killed the vanguard boss
its grey soul can be combined with a
battle x plus six
to create the dozerax and so on if you
kill
blacksmith head he drops the hands of
god a fist weapon that you'll also find
later in this world maybe not the best
idea unless you're about to head into
new game plus
in this game patches is found in the
second stage of two different worlds
after killing the armor spider in the
stonefang tunnels turn left at the fork
and take the elevator the narrower cave
tunnel system will eventually open out
onto a cliff face
with patches waving at you on your left
overcome his poorly thought out trap
talk to him and he'll appear in the
nexus
alternatively you can also find patches
in the second stage
of the shrine of storms in the room
where the reaper cutscene would have
played
here patches is in the room underneath
the reaper
and he'll kick you into a pit that you
can quickly escape from
go back up and talk to him and he'll go
on to appear in the nexus
once he's in the nexus patches will sell
this assortment of valuable consumables
ammunitions rings as well all seen here
sticky white stuff and the cat's ring
will also appear
after killing two arch demons white
arrows and
new moon grass will appear after killing
three
and dark moon grass and a stone of
ephemeral eyes
will appear after killing four
archdemons by the way
are the big bosses at the very end of
each world
consider picking up the cat's ring if
you need to survive long falls
or the fragrant ring to regenerate manna
over time
depending on which world you originally
found patches in
he may leave the nexus at some point to
reappear in the second world that i
mentioned earlier
find him there and he should reappear in
the nexus after his trap
talk to him in the nexus as you progress
through the game for that
juicy lore and he'll often give you new
dialogue about other worlds and npcs
deliver patches his deserved death and
you'll receive the thief's ring which
reduces aggro range but you can more
easily get this in
the first sage of balataria behind
ostrava instead
in the same hole that patches kicked you
into lies the magic sword makoto
which drains your health as you wield it
another character
satsuki craves this weapon and you'll be
able to find him
at the start of the shrine of storms but
he'll only appear
in pure white world tendency and if
you're in this
then you can talk to him here before or
after you have the sword
but no matter what dialogue option you
choose after talking to him with the
sword
he will attack you and he'll attack you
immediately if you're actually
wielding it in front of him he also
appears in pure black world tendency in
the same place as his human form
just kill him and he'll drop hiltless
another npc seeking a powerful weapon
is scurvier the wanderer who is seeking
the dragon bone smasher sword
it's too big to be called a sword really
too big
too thick too heavy and too rough it's
more like a large hunk of iron
anyway you can find the sword in the
arena where you find the dragon god
but you need pure white world tendency
here at which point
some debris will clear which reveals the
weapon take the weapon back to scurvy
in 2-2 so from the arch stone turn into
the right tunnel until you get to the
hole
and then drop very carefully down the
hole and aim for that
tunnel within a rocky precipice
equipping the weapon here and talking to
scurvy
will reward you with a pure greystone
and if you choose to kill him at this
point you can get the ronin's ring
which slows weapon durability loss he
also appears here in pure black world
tendency as a black phantom at
which point he will drop a talisman of
beasts which is this supremely powerful
talisman that
can cast miracles and magic
if you're a faith build then you'll want
to go into the hole where patches kick
to
in 4-2 where you'll find and rescue
saint urbain from the black phantom
guarding the exit
after this he'll appear behind the
boletarian archstone
in the nexus where he will go on to
teach the powerful miracles
seen on screen once you have everything
and exhaust his
changing dialogue throughout the game
kill him to receive the saints
set and also a ring of devout prayer
which allows you to attune another
miracle
saint obain replaces the disciple of god
in the nexus
a character that sells basic miracles if
your faith is above
10 after clearing boletarian palace
urbane will appear alongside the
worshipper of god
who will only talk to you if your faith
is above 20 and
they'll give you the pure faint stone
for your faith build
but if a magic build is more your style
then look to frake's apprentice
who appears on the opposite side of the
nexus if your magic stat
is above 10 after clearing boletarian
palace
he sells these basic spells but he will
eventually be replaced by
sage frake who is locked in a cell in
the first stage of latria
basically just progress as you normally
would through this level until you come
to the main cathedral which is behind
that machine that shoots a ton of arrows
and
also it's the place where you fight the
boss of this area take the stairs up the
right hand tower and then
take the special key behind the praying
dregling from the archstone
freak's cell requires you to turn right
then go up the stairs
go to the other end of the hall go
outside
go back in hug the left wall all the way
to the opposite side again
go downstairs one level and then look to
the cells on the right
rescue frake and he'll give you gary's
stiletto
after this he'll appear in the nexus
offering a much more powerful selection
of spells
as long as you have the boss souls to
exchange for some of the more powerful
ones
once you've exhausted his dialogue and
his spell repertoire throughout the game
kill him to receive the baby's nail
dagger the venerable sage set
and a ring of magical sharpness which
increases your magic attack at the
expense of your magic defense
even more spells can be attained by
rescuing yuria the witch
whose quest line is only accessible
after you've killed an archdemon
who are the bosses at the end of each
world this dissipates the fog
after the tower night fight in boletaria
castle
after which you can go on to clear 1-3
we'll also talk about how to rescue bjor
here since they're right next to each
other
so after you clear 1-3 make sure to kill
the two fat officials in this zone
who will give you a the iron keys and b
a fat official's cap the first official
is seen after the narrow path
with the assassins in it and the second
official is past him
after you get to a point where you can
double back along the main path
all the way back to where the gate first
shut when you first started this level
this second one drops the cap the
leggings and gloves are dropped in 2-1
one across the broken bridge and the
other before the armored spider
and the official's clothes are from
taking the leftmost tunnel
when you spawn in at 2-2 once you have
these items
go back to the 1-3 archstone and then
turn backwards
and face the dragon bridge on the right
is a door that will now unlock
leading to the jail here you can rescue
bjor who we'll talk about more in a
moment
he'll help you kill the fat official in
this area in the jail for the bloody set
of keys
which you'll also need to rescue yuria
once again
go back to 1-3 and this time go forwards
and unlock the door in the alleyway
directly opposite the courtyard with the
dogs
and the abandoned carriages within
there's a tall tower
housing a truly isolated prisoner where
the fat officials set
to fool the fat official above who will
lower the drawbridge
remove the hat and rescue yuria who will
now appear
on the right side of your nexus teaching
the spells seen on screen
killing yuria will reward you with the
old raggedy set
which you can get elsewhere and also the
ring of magical nature
which gives an extra magic slot bio
should be in the nexus 2
at this point offering dialogue as you
progress throughout the game
and during this dialogue he confirms to
you that he will be available for the
penetrator boss fight
in 1-3 all you need to do is enter the
boss fog
and he will be there to make the fight
far far easier
in the original he could actually solo
the penetrator killing beor will grant
you the brushwood set
and shield as well as the ring of great
strength which increases your equipment
capacity load
by 50 the filthy man can be found at the
start of stoneflank tunnel where he
sells the following
then you find him again in 2-2 near a
short drop where you might have found
patches
here his inventory is updated with the
following stone shards killing him
serves no purpose the filthy woman is a
really important
vendor as she is the only way to get
rotten arrows which
inflict poison and she also sells black
turpentine
which is great for this area in the
first stage
hug the right wall and progress along
the linear path
until you spot her in one of the hovels
by some of her wares
to feed her poor child that likely
doesn't exist
and then in the second stage she's found
right after the fog gate
after you clear the swamp here she sells
the miradan set
as well as what you see on screen an
interesting quirk is that she'll also
sell a stone of ephemeral eyes
but only if you're in soul form and
she'll also raise its price
if you're of a higher soul level she's a
bit of an opportunist
the dragling merchant is found in the
first three stages of boletarian palace
and he moves on with this upgraded
inventory as you defeat each boss
go through the fog gate guarded by the
blue-eyed knight and then drop down and
rescue a strava
continue on until you see some debris on
the right the merchant is behind here
and he has this basic inventory of items
in the second stage
get to the first tower on the bridge
head into the basement and then go
directly right
at the end you'll find the merchant with
his wares upgraded to include the
following
of particular note is the claymore and
turpentine
a good weapon and a great buff in 1-3
progressed through the stage until you
come to this
narrow alley with those assassin
ambushes coming out of the other end you
should kill the archers
and then take out the redeye knight in
the room to your right
upstairs once again is the draggling
merchant with an inventory that now
includes the items on screen
a particular note here is the brushwood
gear which you can buy here
if bjor survives the fight with the
penetrator
grave rob oblige can be rescued in the
first stage of the shrine of storms
as long as you get the copper key which
you'll find by going left
through the main castle wall go up the
stairs onto the top of the ramparts
run all the way to the opposite side go
down the stairs and
there it is then once you have the key
go through the castle wall
run past the demon vanguard and then
drop down into this sort of collapsed
dungeon that's behind it
at the end is a cell with oblige who
sells the items
on screen his inventory does upgrade
after you come across him in a tunnel
near the first reaper in 4-2
and he moves here as well it now
includes an assortment of ranged
ammunition
and some new shard materials killing him
will net you a grave robber's ring
which reduces your aggro range against
black phantom enemies
sparkly the crow can also be found in
the first stage of the shrine of storms
and
she'll accept an assortment of items for
trade these ones in particular
are the trades that i highly recommend
turn left within the castle wall
go up the stairs drop down through the
ruined wall
and then head up the stairs again to
leave via the exit
that has an earthy sort of hill at the
top is sparkly who will trade items with
you if you drop the right things for her
the list is on screen and these trades
can only be made once
now stockpile thomas is a really
important npc to understand for
he stores anything that you give him
lessening your load
it's especially important that you give
him your ore since that ore will still
be usable at the blacksmith's
despite it being in thomas inventory not
yours
he does have one quick quest line
available in 1-1
of boletaria after the stone boulder
rolls down the stairs
go to the opposite side of the ramparts
and take the stairs down until you find
a balcony with two chains
cut them then continue down and out of
the tower
where you'll find items on the corpses
they were suspending
one of these is the jade hair ornament
which belonged to his daughter
and can be given to him in exchange for
the ring of herculean strength
which increases item weight capacity by
50 percent
alternatively you can kill him to get
this ring you monster
ostrava is the classic questline for
demon souls and he appears for you
throughout boletaria castle
requiring help at three different points
first
travel to 1-1 kill the blue knight
guiding the fog gate and then look for
him shortly after
over a short drop talk to him and then
kill the dreglings lying in ambush
talk to him again and receive the brass
telescope next he'll appear in 1-2
on a path to the left after defeating
phalanx
here he'll require rescuing from the
enemies in the tunnel
on the other side so to get there you go
to the basement of the first
tower on the bridge and then you double
back towards him
talk to him to receive three darkmoon
grass
if you do this in 1-3 you'll come across
him being attacked on the other side of
the main gate
where he'll once again require rescue to
get here
simply double back along the path after
you get to the sort of main road
that leads to the penetrator boss fight
finally he'll appear in 1-4
in the end game after your encounter
with the blue dragon
talk to him to receive the mausoleum key
and then kill his black phantom shortly
after
to receive his rune sword and rune
shield
you can kill him earlier to receive the
mausoleum key
which unlocks the door to old king duran
located in 1-1 at the end of the
ramparts
that has a red-eye spear knight guarding
the mausoleum
old king duran challenges you to deal
enough damage to him
in order to prove your worth at which
time he'll reward you with demon brand
one of the king's twin swords if you
continue to attack him he will become
hostile at half health
and he'll drop his armor if you kill him
and the eternal warrior's ring which
increases the rate
of your stamina regeneration to rescue
lord rydell
you must have pure white world tendency
which can be achieved by defeating the
first three bosses in this world
without dying in body form keep yourself
in soul form by killing yourself in the
nexus if you have to
starting from the 1-3 archstone make
your way to the giant
tower and then take the stairs until you
get to the first walkway on the left
follow it to the very end and then make
your way up to the very top of the next
tower
where you'll find the prison of hope
second floor west key
so to get there spawn in at the first
level of latria
and progress along the path to the right
take the stairs
then make your way to the opposite side
of the main hall
get outside go back inside then take the
left hand side
to the very end of the hall again go
downstairs all the way
ignore the door on the right just go
straight through this corridor and then
stay
on this level and make your way to the
end of this hall once again
on the left will be riddle who will give
you the dull rat's ring
which increases your defense at low
health after he's freed the gate near
the arrow machine
unlocks leading to a bunch of loot and
ridiel's
legendary soul freeing ridiel has no
bearing on his black phantom questline
which requires
pure black world tendency meaning you
just have to die in this world
a bunch of times in body form he appears
outside his cell as a black phantom
and when he's killed he drops his weapon
the phosphorescent pole
next is yurt who has a questline of
death unless you take the short route
and
just kill him immediately after rescuing
him to
find yurt start at the fool's idol
archestone
head towards the giant heart tower go
upstairs and take the first path on the
left
at the end of the path go all the way up
to the top of the next tower
and then look around for this platform
that has a bunch of coloured stones
scattered around it yott is signaling
for help here
but when you rescue him it will
immediately have consequences
when you head back to the nexus you'll
be able to find two
unnamed corpses leading you towards
where yurt is lurking
and this is just the beginning every
time you return you'll find another dead
character
and the deaths become more and more
significant as you go on
the apprentices then patches then urbain
freak
yuria yurt will take out most of the
characters you worked to bring back to
the nexus
and when they're all dead only one human
remains to kill
you so what you do is you kill him first
because you've played this game before
or you've watched this
video before and you know what's coming
so just kill him
and you get his awesome armor to get
selen vinland's armor and ring from her
questline
you'll need to go to the second level of
the valley of defilement
then run from island to island on the
main path through the swamp
and when you hit the fog gate look for
her in the swamp
on the right side of the scaffolding she
only appears here
in pure white world tendency asking
about her brother gal
who is a part of the last boss fight in
this world
during your fight with him he'll drop
his armor his shield
and the crest of finland which you can
return to her
in return for a ring of devout prayer
which gives you an extra miracle slot
however what you really want from her is
herrama which you'll get along with her
ring
just for killing her don't do that just
yet though first
take advantage of your pure white world
tendency
and warp to the dirty colossus archstone
go back into the boss cavern and gal
will be there in black phantom form
where he'll drop his weapon brammed
killing cylin afterwards will move your
world's tendency towards black
which when pure will cause her to appear
here
as a black phantom rewarding you with
her weapon blind upon death which
goes through shields executioner miralda
is another npc that so many miss
because who goes back to boletaria 1-1
towards the end of the game
she's here in the area off to the left
at the start of boletaria
behind a gate that will only open in
pure white world tendency
kill her for her armor set and the
master's ring which
increases damage done by weapons that
have a precise hit
reward like axes and hammers she also
appears here in pure black world
tendency
as a black phantom dropping the
guillotine axe crest fallen just has an
incredible quest line where
if you exhaust his dialogue and have
killed the tower knight he'll disappear
and leave behind
a storied soldier's soul but maybe don't
exhaust his dialogue and
just keep him around for a little while
as you might want to murder him later
to help lower your character world
tendency to pure
black at which point mephistopheles will
appear
as long as you've also killed yurt who
we talked about earlier
so meth is another assassination npc
and unlike yurt who needs to be dead at
this point she encourages
you to kill her targets in return for a
reward
for everyone that you kill if one of her
targets is already dead then you won't
get any reward and she'll just skip
to the next one on her list here is the
list of her targets by the way
and here are the rewards that you get
for killing them a special note is the
foes ring which increases damage as a
black phantom
and you get that from killing yuria the
witch at the end of it all
mephistopheles will try to kill you and
she'll drop her mask
the ep rapier and the ring of the
accursed upon death
now the monumental she sort of has one
quest line where you receive the friends
ring as long as
your character tendency is pure white
this ring increases your damage by
twenty percent as a blue phantom
and it's kind of the opposite of the
foes ring which increases your damage by
twenty percent as a black phantom
to get pure white character tendency
you'll have to kill
all five named black phantoms who can
only be found in pure black world
tendency
so to kill all of those characters you
have to blow the world's tendency of
each world containing them
all the way to pure black which
obviously takes a while but luckily
thanks to this video
we did talk about all five of those
named black phantoms in this video so
just skip around and figure out how to
kill all of them in order to get your
character tendency up to pure white
so you'll have to kill miralda scurvy
lord rudiel
satsuki and selen vinland then you can
go talk to the monumental and you'll
hopefully
have pure white character tendency the
only other npcs worth mentioning are
blacksmith baldwin the once royal
mistress and the maiden in black
who are no good to you dead and don't
really have any quest lines so
just leave them alive although i suppose
there is an exception with the maiden in
black
at the end of the game as long as you
take the good ending and
don't kill her then you'll receive her
demon soul
and then you can exchange that with
yuria for the spell
soul sucker subscribe to learn
everything there is to know about demon
souls
and i'll see you next time so before i
go i want to say that
this amazing outro was commissioned from
kevin's computer so that's at kevin's
underscore computer
if you want to follow them on twitter i
love this i've never seen anyone doing
artwork in this kind of
nostalgic 3d cartoonish art style
and they were a joy to work with so
consider following them
thank you kevin and yeah thanks for
watching guys